E aí
[Música]
os
[Aplausos]
[Música]
seus sonhos Nunca desista
dos seus sonhos sempre foi meus que me
guiam sempre foi Deus que me ajudou
a vida é linda
Sorria a vida é boa Tudo Que Quiser vai
conseguir
que Deus está aqui
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e fez os animais toda a beleza e ele
criou o mar e o infinito Ele me trouxe a
paz e o amor mais bonito
[Música]
dos seus sonhos Cadê sexta dos seus
sonhos e sempre foi Deus que me ganhou
[Música]
agradeço a Deus por minha vida
pela saúde pela família
por eu quero mais e poder cantar ter
amigos para compartilhar
toda alegria tudo que é de bom tudo que
a terra dividir o pão a ver o sol nascer
ver o sol se pôr sempre
agradecer ao nosso Senhor
[Música]
por causa desse está na pão um
cada exista um
e Essa sou eu sou cantora
multi-instrumentista
a música estava na minha vida desde bebê
eu nasci prematura devido uma infecção
urinária que acabou complicado a
gestação
nasce 28 semanas de gestação
pesando
894 gramas medindo 33cm
fiquei 62 dias de UTI e berçário com o
tamanho que eu tinha uma energia
incrível e uma vontade de viver enorme
com 3 meses de vida a mãe me levou uma
consulta no oftalmologista
aonde o médico já disse que teria que
encaminhar para particular urgente
e a mãe com depressão muito forte conta
que não lembra nem como chegou na
clínica comigo no colo estava tomando
antidepressivos
chegando lá ela conta que o médico me
examinou e olhou para mim fixamente e
disse Meu Deus mãe sua filha está
ficando cega
Ele arrumou os papéis para cirurgia na
época os pais não tinham condições de
pagar 9000 cada Vista seria aplicações
em gel para tentar reverter a doença e
começou uma nova fase da minha vida
o meu primeiro contato com a música Foi
quando a professora sentava comigo no
tapete ouvimos música e ela fazia
estimulação visual em frente a caixinha
de luzes e lá a gente ficava
ela pegava nas minhas mãos e fazia vão
movimento
há 8 meses de vida eu batia meus pés na
parede de madeira fazendo ritmos
frequentes no meu primeiro aniversário
ganhei um teclado de presente da voz
Abel até nos seis anos eu batia nas
teclas e dançava
eu sempre fui inclusa nas apresentações
da Escola fui em creche em Jardim sempre
fui tratada como uma criança normal em
casa sou eu e mais três irmãos eu sou a
segunda da casa
no pré já conhecia as letras do meu nome
tive uma professora que foi uma mãe para
mim me ensinou tudo do pré 1 até o 5º
ano ela esteve comigo
hoje tenho 12 anos em agosto fez um ano
que ganhei o que lê tem ouvido absoluto
para a música
e isso torna o meu aprendizado mais
fácil e o meu sonho é bom dia me
apresentar para uma multidão de pessoas
[Música]
dos seus sonhos sempre foi meu Deus que
me guia sempre foi Deus que me ajudou
a vida é linda
Sorria a vida é boa Tudo Que Quiser vai
conseguir
que Deus está aqui ó
[Música]
os pés os animais toda a beleza
Ele criou o mar e o infinito Ele me
trouxe a passe o amor mais bonito
[Música]
dos seus sonhos Cadê
sentado seus sonhos e sempre foi Deus
que me criou
[Música]
agradeço a Deus por minha vida
pela saúde pela família
por eu quero mais e poder cantar ter
amigos para compartilhar
toda alegria tudo que é de bom
e a terra dividir o pão ver o sol nascer
ver o sol se pôr sempre
agradecer ao nosso Senhor
[Música]
por causa de sexta na mão
um cada se
estar muito obrigado pessoal
[Música]
E aí